Nos dicen: "Alejandra está en una rueda
de la fortuna. Su altura desde el suelo,
en metros, está modelada por H(t),
donde t es el tiempo en segundos",
y podemos verla por aquí. Ahora bien, en
este video quiero que nos enfoquemos en
algunas características de esta gráfica.
La primera característica en la que nos
enfocaremos es la línea media, así que
pausa el video e intenta encontrar la
línea media de esta gráfica o de esta función
y después pensaremos qué representa realmente.
Bueno, Alejandra empieza a 5 m del suelo y después
sube y sube y sube hasta llegar a 25 m, luego baja
de nuevo a 5 m para después subir otra vez a 25 m
del suelo. Y podemos pensar la línea media como el
punto medio entre estos dos extremos o el promedio
de estos extremos, entonces los extremos que
tenemos son 5 m, el más bajo, y 25 m, el más alto.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el promedio de 5 y 25? Bueno,
es 15, la línea media se va a ver algo así
y vamos a seguir hasta salir de la gráfica,
ya que esto nos ayudará a pensar lo que representa
la línea media. Una forma de pensarlo es que,
en esta situación, representa el centro de nuestra
rotación o la altura desde el suelo del centro de
nuestra rueda de la fortuna. Para ayudarnos a
visualizar esta idea, dibujemos una rueda de la
fortuna: vamos a dibujar un círculo con este punto
como su centro y entonces se va a ver algo así,
y tal vez tenga una estructura de soporte,
así que la rueda de la fortuna se va a ver,
se verá más o menos así. Y esta altura desde el
suelo es 15 m, lo que representa la línea media.
Ahora, la siguiente característica que quiero
que exploremos es la amplitud. Pausa el video
y piensa cuál es la amplitud de esta función
oscilante y después pensaremos qué representa
o de dónde sale en el mundo real. Bueno, la
amplitud es la diferencia máxima o la magnitud
máxima desde la línea media. Podemos ver aquí
que en el momento en el que Alejandra empieza a
moverse está a 10 m por debajo de la línea media,
es decir, 10 m por debajo del centro. Esto sucede
cuando Alejandra está justo aquí, está 10 m por
debajo de la línea media; después de 10 segundos,
ella está justo en la línea media, eso significa
que estaría justo aquí. Tal vez la rueda de la
fortuna vaya en esta dirección, al menos en mi
mente va en sentido horario, y después de otros
10 segundos está a 25 m del suelo, es decir, está
justo acá. Intencionalmente dibuje el círculo de
este tamaño y así podemos ver la amplitud con
claridad: 10 m por debajo de la línea media y
10 m por arriba de la línea media. Entonces, la
amplitud es el desplazamiento máximo o el cambio
máximo desde esa línea media. Aquí podemos ver
que representa el radio de nuestra rueda de la
fortuna, 10 m; después de ese punto, ella empieza
a bajar de nuevo y por aquí regresa al punto
de partida. Bien, la última característica que
quiero que exploremos es la noción de periodo,
¿cuál es el periodo de esta función
periódica? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
El periodo es el tiempo que lleva a completar un
ciclo. Empieza aquí, en el punto mínimo, después
de 10 segundos no está aún en el punto mínimo,
después de 20 segundos aún no regresa al punto
mínimo, después de 30 segundos todavía no llega al
punto mínimo y justo aquí, después de 40 segundos,
regresa de nuevo al punto mínimo, lista para
volver a empezar. Entonces, el periodo son
40 segundos. Si pensamos qué es lo que ocurre
por aquí, ella empieza en este punto que está
a 5 m desde el suelo, después de 10 segundos ella
está aquí, que corresponde a este punto de aquí,
después de otros 10 segundos se encuentra por
acá, que corresponde a este punto, después
de 10 segundos más ella se encuentra aquí, que
corresponde a este punto, y 10 segundos después,
es decir, después de 40 segundos en total,
Alejandra regresa a donde empezó. Así que, en
este ejemplo, el periodo muestra en cuánto tiempo
se completa una rotación. Ahora, debemos tener
cuidado al inspeccionar visualmente el periodo, ya
que algunas veces estaremos tentados a decir "Ok,
si empezamos aquí, a 15 m desde el suelo, después
bajamos, subimos y, mira, de nuevo estamos a 15
m del suelo, tal vez estos 20 segundos es el
periodo"; pero cuando lo veamos aquí es claro
que no es así. Este punto representa este punto
en la rueda de la fortuna, que está a 15 metros
del suelo, bajamos hasta llegar a este punto, y
después de 10 segundos más llegaremos a este otro
punto. Observa: esto que tenemos aquí es solamente
medio ciclo, recorrimos la mitad, pero para dar
la vuelta completa no sólo debemos llegar a la
misma altura, además tenemos que movernos en la
misma dirección: aquí, al bajar, llegamos a 15 m
del suelo, por acá estamos a 15 m del suelo, pero
vamos subiendo, no vamos en la misma dirección
aún, así que tenemos que seguir moviéndonos
otros 20 segundos hasta llegar de nuevo a 15 m
del suelo, pero que, otra vez, vayamos bajando.